there must be lights burning brighter
somewhere
got to be birds flying higher in the Sky
Hi everybody my name is Alan lights I am
a music journalist and author and a host
on Sirius XM Satellite Radio joined here
by a bunch of the team who worked on
baslerman's remarkable film Elvis
director producer co-writer baz Lerman
actor Austin Butler cinematographer
Mandy Walker production designer Karen
Murphy re-recording mixer Michael Keller
and editor Jonathan Redmond we're going
to be seeing the inspiration the
creation and the performance of If I Can
Dream the climactic moments of the 1968
Comeback Special Elvis came back from
the Army in 1960 and pretty immediately
agreed to a contract set up by manager
Colonel Tom Parker that locked him into
multiple movies with multiple
soundtracks every year and that was
pretty much the extent of his work
through most of the 1960s by 1968 his
sales were down his relevance was
tumbling in addition 1968 of course was
a time of tremendous turmoil in the
United States with the assassinations of
Dr Martin Luther King Robert F Kennedy
the Democratic Convention chaos in the
culture there was a feeling that the
world probably like insane ways in 9 11
that the World As We Knew It was just
being ripped apart and I mean if MLK
could be shot by the way
30 minutes from Elvis's home in Memphis
right
you know and RFK could be shot you know
what kind of world are we in
it would be just as wrong and just as
self-deceptive to conclude from this act
of violence that our country itself is
sick
it's lost its power
lost its sense of direction even it's
common decent finding that speech from
President Johnson was real key and it
just unlocked so much emotion in the
scene and working with that stock
footage was uh
really fantastic it really kind of
anchored the scene emotionally and just
felt really really powerful my fellow
citizens we cannot
we just must not pause
him Among Us we must not permit men that
are filled with hate suddenly Elvis is
irrelevant Elvis is over
and the kernels actually got to a point
where my they're making a river of money
and it says now boys here's the script
here's all of the Christmas songs Elvis
is going to sing he had them already
here's the radio you just do that and
you're going to have a great time
[Music]
Here Comes
[Music]
right down Santa Claus
Elvis says look I really need help to
get back to who I am and they and they
said you know what about the colonel
what does he think this is factual
dialogue and he said he says I don't
give a damn what the colonel thinks and
for that moment when he says just one
thing
could we do gospel because you see
gospel was Elvis a safe place
we're pretty set for the number tomorrow
right EP
it's pretty familiar territory right
Reverend once told me
when things are too dangerous to say
ing Elvis is really struggling and that
night you know one of the things about
Elvis was and Austin can tell you this
in a much better way because nobody
knows more about Elvis Presley than
Austin Butler I have to tell you that
but what we tell the story did happen it
was did stay up all night they did write
that song and Elvis
turn the lights out and he recorded that
song over and over and over and over
again in embryonic position on the floor
there must be light
lights Burning Bright
somewhere
and got to be birds flying higher in the
sky
a more blue so Austin for you what to
approach this moment which is
this again this pivot point in this
entire story I mean this moment of him
deciding to take this risk deciding to
stand up to the colonel how did you
approach all of the different emotions
all of the different things that are
going on for him as we walk into this
scene I always knew this moment was was
pivotal and you know you know it was it
was this seismic shift in the rest of
Elvis's career I had had two years of
preparation leading up to this this
moment when we're finally going to shoot
68 which is not not only one of the most
important moments in Elvis's career but
it's one of the most iconic moments in
Rock and Roll history and uh and so I've
done all the homework and and and
watched the footage you know every hour
that I could
um but then the moment of truth comes
when you got to shoot it and and you
realize that all this work that's that
everybody has put in needs to be caught
within this Frame and it's between
action and cut that that is the moment
of truth and uh so I felt a lot of
responsibility and pressure and and fear
that goes along with that and and this
feeling of if it didn't go well that I'd
probably never work again you know that
a lot of people have trusted me a lot of
people have supported me and uh and
believed in me and but if I go out there
and I fail then it will all be for
nothing and and that feeling of my
career could be over
I I thought that's exactly what Elvis is
feeling
so this isn't this isn't a bad thing
that I'm feeling this I can actually
this is actually a good thing and you
we're seeing all all that was happening
in the world around that time and uh and
it just made me think of that time in
the late 60s and all that's happening in
the world at that time and the chaos and
the confusion and singing the words of
If I Can Dream felt just as poignant in
when we shot it as as I imagine did back
then so that was my own personal
experience that then I was able to
really have an out of Body Experience
because you know I spent the countless
hours being meticulous about what his
fingers were doing or what his eyes were
doing in a certain moment at that point
it was in my bones and I could I could
release that in a way and just focus on
the spirit of the music and and uh that
was that was my experience
standing by we're seconds away folks
seconds away was waiting on upstairs
we're going to get a rehearsal going
very shortly let's go let's go people
first positions here we go from the top
the colonist said I've got the founder I
found the Telex actually in Graceland in
a box that said if you don't do a
Christmas song it will be sued and I'll
leave you like he he really does that
because the colonel has said Elvis
Presley does not do message songs quite
a homemaker is and I'm sure she would
love to have one of the SK 551 machines
so she can knit other system they were
in there all night doing what yeah he's
working on a new song he says he's
singing a new song oh hey it's beginning
to look a lot like Christmas yes
gentlemen
foreign
now that's a winter wonderland
Mr Bender you and I are on the same page
bring up the lights on the Sun
okay yeah let's go and Mandy obviously
it's the baslerman movie there's a lot
of things visually going on but talk
about from your end particularly as we
go into this moment
well uh this because this um performance
exists online we were going to replicate
this concert
exactly as it was and you can and
Austin's performance was exactly the
same as Elvis and so between myself and
and Karen will tell you the art
Department we got together to
um replicate the the environment and the
set and then we've scoured Australia for
period
um light fixtures for the TV studio and
um and for and the cameras that were in
the TV studio as well we put one of our
film cameras into the housing of the TV
camera so it'd be in exactly the right
position to get the same angle so it was
the technical part of it as well but
also was getting
um as we called it the cameras to be
able to dance with Austin and that was
about preparation and rehearsal and we
would rehearse with him on stage so that
by the time we shot it we're all in
harmony similar to Mandy we you know
obviously the the special exists so we
poured over all the detail obviously
it's hard to find drawings of all these
things so we literally were scaling we
were looking at the size of people and
trying to scale how big the actual Elvis
sign was and and all of those details
then again there are the elements that
help to build the emotion in that scene
which are Steve Bender and bones are at
the top they're they're overlooking him
they can see him there from that control
room that wasn't necessarily the way
that geography worked in reality but it
worked for those being able to see that
in the background and having that
Christmas set just sitting there just
sort of while everyone's gone home for
the day it's just sort of this little uh
detail there which I think is quite
beautiful that it's still there and it's
present and he's looking at he's looking
over it and he's looking at them so all
of those things we were of course being
very true to the period with the the
control room and the studio itself for
what you actually see in the 1968
special so with those performances that
have been put on on film and they're
there forever we were very meticulous
about that we also needed to serve the
story and the emotion in those sense
[Music]
who is too much rain
you're trapped in a world
that's trouble with pain
but as long as a man
has tricks to a dream he can redeem his
soul
we had to compress time so Karen or
Kazar as I sometimes call them said it
very well we do use license we do use
devices there's no no question about
that and you'll start with seeing all
Elvis Austin and Elvis same person
starting to kind of Mark out the song
that's Austin singing by the time we get
to the end though that very famous
recording that I was actually dead
laying on the ground gut-wrenching all
of that it turns into Elvis's real voice
so we have to try and get this kind of
seamless progression going from this
very intimate moment where they're
rehearsing building a song that he comes
the colonel there's an even extension
here it comes and then yet Elvis comes
on and triumphs you know and it's all in
a short period of time it's such an
important song and uh what people might
not know is that Austin sang it full
heart
every song and that gave us the choice
to go back and forth in and out between
Austin singing which in this scene is
him singing in the beginning and then
transitioning into the Elvis original
tracks and Austin I wish you could sing
it today because I think the world needs
it today as well and you know you're the
current Elvis oh man Austin please give
us some sense of what it was for you to
inhabit these songs
uh it was extraordinary I mean I knew
that I
I wanted to set out to sing Everything
as though it was what was going to be
used in the film
um
for a couple reasons one of which being
that's that's how Elvis expressed his
own emotion and and uh and just the The
Genius of him and his musicality so I
knew that that was such a key into his
spirit so I I never wanted to be miming
anything and and I also even if there
was a moment where
where I thought you know this is such an
iconic moment of Elvis's voice that they
you guys may decide to want to use his
voice in this moment I uh I wanted to
know that I was singing it as as full
out as I I could
um because it connected me spiritually
to him when you sing full out
and and you're you're connecting to the
same intonations and breath you end up
being taken on this ride emotionally and
uh and and you're saying certain words
that that connect to your heart and I I
mean I feel very fortunate because in a
way I got to go on this journey uh with
every song that I sang as Elvis that was
I I can't imagine anybody having a
closer experience to what Elvis got to
experience in that moment then when
you're there you're just you just you're
just a spirit of the music and what that
song means then you end up feeling like
you're able to merge with him in those
choices you know and
um yes it was very special for me
[Music]
still I am sure that the answers
is Gonna Come somehow out there in the
dark
there's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
right now
let it come true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Goosebumps that particular performance
was only on like 12 track or something
like that it was a very very degraded
performance it's great but Elliot so
cleverly reconstructed the
orchestrations and it was able to pull
the original vocal and also blend at
Boston's I mean it's such a complicated
layering and in the mix I mean it was so
intricate to do that and even I can't
work out which one's Austin which one's
Elvis it's kind of amazing to see
quick question for Jonathan but Vaz has
talked about the compressing time the
end of this scene when he finishes I Can
Dream you get this sort of a collage to
give a sense of the impact of this
moment how to just figuring out those
sort of shorthands to be able to get all
this story just give us a quick sense of
that well Buzz came up with a an
expression which he used we used to call
poetic blue
um
and I think we came I think it was The
Great Gatsby bands is that correct we
came up with poetic glue
um
yeah
and it's basically kind of shorthand for
um layering kind of extra information
visually on top of the picture uh so we
see that collage of different uh
headlines uh that appears towards the
end of the song to uh add extra
information to uh to give to the
audience without adding time so I think
in the end our solution which was just
him on magazines just gave you what you
needed to know that he was back that it
really affected culture because we said
this is a pivot point into a next
chapter
but we all know how this story ends
everybody walks into the theater knowing
how this story ends what is this scene
set in motion and set up that then you
know rolls down to what the ending of
the movie becomes and the ending of the
story becomes oh man I I think this is
this is one of the high points of
Elvis's life and artistic uh artistic
life for sure but it but it does set in
motion
some great times of of you know all the
music that comes in the late 60s and
early 70s that gives way to Vegas which
those that those first couple of shows
in Vegas God I wish I was there I mean
you will I I feel like I was well I wish
I was in the audience uh you know
getting it getting to watch I mean from
the 69 show or all the music that he was
recording you know when he goes back
that person
um you know and into the 70s but then
then he gets stuck in that gilded cage
and and uh and we know the ending but um
that's what sort of sets in motion that
that new chapter of his of his musical
life and did to create some of the
greatest music I think ever made
and baz for you what's the you know from
this moment to that you know to to the
to the ending moments what what what's
playing against each other it was
triumphs and he realizes that by
believing in his own instincts and going
back to gospel it sets him free and as a
consequence he goes back to his roots
Memphis and those American Studio
recordings chips Melman all of that
that's the great great Elvis music I
mean he's truly involved in our music
and he even defies the colonel again
about the publishing over Suspicious
Minds he went back he did his own music
he started to spread his wings he was
going to get on that plane and fly away
but that old colonel was a tricky fish
that we know it drama ensues
and tragedy actually tragedy tragedy for
sure
well thank you baslerman Austin Butler
Mandy Walker Karen Murphy Michael Keller
and Jonathan Redmond all here
representing Elvis
I'm Alan light thank you all for
watching thanks Alan thank you thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]